right before Christmas a good guy in red
he's coming to theaters with his new
sidekick
Fred why am I here so I could read you
the story of Deadpool to filtered
through the prison of childlike
innocence you'd say for grandma's I love
you're working up and approve for teams
for the first time ever
Deadpool's pg-13 the only half bomber
using around here is Fred Savage once
upon a Deadpool rated pg-13 in theaters
December 12 right before Christmas a
good guy in red is coming to theaters
with his new sidekick
Fred why am I here you're in a pg-13
version of Deadpool filtered through the
prison of childlike innocence and nobody
does childlike innocence like you Fred
no buddy I need you almost as much as
you need me I don't need you at all me
to untie you
once we're done
[Music]
I loved your working up I'm sorry
don't get to a test one so Paul no
Deadpool character for Marvel movies we
are Merkel yeah but you're you know
Marvel license by Fox it's like if the
Beatles were produced by Nickelback it's
music but it sucks you were nicer as a
kid rated pg-13 limited engagement in
theaters December 12th
you